you know who's kind of working with us
somewhat in the other in our podcast and
other stuff and his name got brought up
in our podcast and then the students
like he was after he goes hey I gotta
tell you this story man like he goes I
was always a big fan of Carlos man I you
know I loved the [ __ ] he saw at a
Chipotle or something not long ago I
know what yet I know but just I don't
want to you know think about that that
makes me laugh go ahead okay
were you gonna make just because he's I
did or the fact that he's half German
and Honduran and he's in a Chipotle
because that's Mexican is that where
you're gonna go that's specific no II
just think if somebody was talking about
me and they said yeah we saw a barbecue
on Vermont Panda Express handing that
would because I'll tell you why not I'll
tell you why I'm not in a pen Express
well the reveal happening I love Penn
Express I'm not trying to get Chinese
yeah okay so let's so why is that okay
so that's okay you go in the Panda
Express forget it let's chip hole but is
it this at every foot wait a minute real
quick here and in two minutes you
probably just go there I won't forget I
will not forget your leg you've a long
list now hold on I will not forget okay
is the first time I guess that notes no
I got a hold on I got to do this oh I
won't remember anything okay okay
wait a minute I have this discussion
with Ruben Paul and he's like I don't
even know how you step into a panic sir
psycho Panda Express
we have Taco Bell's Dale tacos
Chipotle's we got all these place why
can't there be Asian places that I mean
I've never gone into a Yoshi Noah I
don't even know what they sell them what
is it mystery meat they have this thing
where it's like curled beef over rice I
used to eat it when I was drunk a lot
because it's so cheap yeah they're
everywhere
they're ever but I never see I don't
know if I see people really see it there
like
Yoshinoya is it was that the jet is that
Japanese yes like a Japanese RVs right
Oh whenever you drive by yeah I never
see anyone in there no on yeah open oh
that's all the time I never I have never
seen no Yoshinoya going out of yeah okay
speaking of me don't worry I'm on track
okay funny stuff
speaking of me yeah okay I never
realized I never thought about this okay
we don't look at my girlfriend and say
speaking of me don't ever don't ever
[ __ ] do that again his voice drop you
want like speaking of me Andrea
don't worry about it baby go ahead so so
I met this dude I did a show and after
the show this guy used to work at Taco
Bell I never really thought about this
yeah but he goes hey man you know that's
that the meat the beef I I don't know
yeah what about eggs like you know you
know you know what it is right and I go
I have no idea
yeah okay so they got you know those
heating pans like yeah okay he goes uh
what they do is it's a package of white
powder and they pour it into the water
and they start stirring it and it
becomes the meat Wow did you know this
no I didn't know that so then I go I
kept going
you're blowing my my there's no way he
goes hey have you ever smelled cooked
meat in there have you ever had a Burt
Taco where the meats overcooked
all right I go oh [ __ ] no he's own
that's what that's what and this was
about five years ago I don't know if
they've shoki so it's just let me get
you get a straight no belts it's
synthetic
if you go up to like in the kitchen
there's probably like a bucket right a
barrel full of this white powder it's a
powder rice water and the powder and it
becomes a thumbs meat that brown stuff
correct
Wow that's what I said Wow
I'm gonna go take care of the dogs okay
go take care of the dogs man okay stop
Rasengan cuz I like because I love every
I don't want to ruin the flow
of anything
[Music]